POINT START BY WINNING THE DRAW
LIGHTNING PLAY.
>> TEAMMATE NOAH
GREGOR.
HERE IS A CHANCE FOR SAN JOSE.
OUT OF THJOSE.
DOESN'T GET VERY FAR., PUSHING
ON THE LINE CHANGE.
THAT'S WELL ABOVE THE GAME PER
AVERAGE OF 25 AND S CIRELLI.
PULLING BACK.
THEY SCORE.
ANTHONY CIRELLI TAPS TO THE LIN
THAT IS A GOAL.
IT WAS NOT EVEN GOING TO   DROP
THERE IS HURTLE, IT'S MEIER.  H
MEIER DROPS IT OFF HER BURNS.
BUTHE CORNER BANKS IT
BACK FOR HEDMAN.
HEDMAN TO STAMKOS.
514.
REBOUND.
IT'S GOOD.IS TERRIFIC.E SECOND
LATE STAGES OF IT  AS THE
PENALTY SETTLES, THE LIGHTNING
THE SHOT SCORES. JUST HAS TO HO
STICK AND GET THE RIGHT ANGLE
ON IT AND THERE IS NOTHING  DOE
JOSEPH CAN'T QUITE KILLORN.
UP AND DOWN SERGACHEV CIRELLI
COMBINATION.T COMES
BACK TO SERGACHEV AND DRIVES, I
GREAT MOVES BY BRADEN POINT
AGAIN GETTING THE
CIRELLI DROPS IT BACK.
IT'S'S
VICTOR HAD BEEN COMING RUTTA SW
CIRELLI, STAMKOS AND GOT A PIEC
AND THE NET COMES CONTROL HERE.
>> Dave:
VICTOR HEDMAN WITH A LIGHTN